merci d'être avec nous que c'est encore
cette première demi heure vous êtes
sénateur républicain du val de marne
vous présidez la commission des affaires
étrangères de la défense et des forces
armées ici au sénat on va bien sûr
longuement parlé de ce qui se passe en
ukraine ce 9 mai jour de la victoire en
russie qui va célébrer laquelle la
capitulation de l'allemagne nazie est ce
qu'il faut craindre ce que va faire
vladimir poutine aujourd'hui
bien évidemment personne ne sait à
l'heure actuelle ce que poutine va dire
dans ce discours que tout le monde
attend avec inquiétude
on parle d'une véritable déclaration de
guerre ce qui donnerait au président
russe la possibilité de mobiliser par
conscription ce qui montrerait du reste
j'allais dire par comparaison la
faiblesse de la situation de l'armée
russe actuellement rien n'indique pour
l'instant et les renseignements que nous
avions encore il ya rien n'indique pour
l'instant que la voie de la paix est en
route les négociations sont quasiment au
point mort les différents interlocuteurs
qui ont tenté une action je pense aux
turcs et cetera aucune médiation ne
débouche et pour l'instant les nouvelles
sont chaque jour au pire en pire 60
morts dans le bombardement d'une école
est ce qu'il y avait des nazis dans une
école d'enfants enfin ça laisse
évidemment pantois et froid effrayés de
cette situation moi je défends la
crainte selon laquelle selon le syndrome
du chien enragé au fond de l'impasse qui
ne voyaient aucune solution se retourne
et vous mort et donc rien n'est exclu a
priori même si personne ne le souhaite
rien exclu l'utilisation d'armes encore
plus dangereuse je pense à des armes
tactiques
soutenu qu les airs sous la barre de ce
qui a été malheureusement fait hiroshima
mais qui peuvent faire effectivement
beaucoup de beaucoup de morts ce serait
évidemment un changement complet dans la
situation espérons que là la raison
l'emportera mais avec quelqu'un comme le
président russe actuellement on commence
à s'interroger vraiment quand vous dites
il est capable du pire pour vous c'est
ça le pire
l'arme nucléaire pour oui parce que ce
serait évidemment un bouleversement
mondial ce serait un choc au delà bien
évidemment des victimes des conséquences
risquent il y a toujours un risque vous
avez le risque de d'un d'un incident
d'un enchaînement d'incidents d'un
missile qui tombe à côté ou qu'ils
tombent sur un pays de l'otan la pologne
n'est pas loin la roumanie où j'étais il
ya quelques semaines n'est pas loin non
plus donc on peut effectivement avoir ce
risque là et c'est ce pourquoi nos
forces armées et celles de l'otan sont
en alerte maximale actuellement ce qui
est une bonne chose car il faut
véritablement être très vigilant quand
on a affaire à des comportements
parfaitement erratique comme comme celui
de poutine est ce qu'aujourd'hui
les buts de guerre
on les recherche va on comprend qu
effectivement initialement la volonté de
poutine s'était 7 ce désir de
reconstituer l'empiré soviétique où l'
empire de catherine de russie on ne sait
plus très bien à quelle référence il
faut faire appel
mais là on voit malheureusement que la
réalité lui a sauté au nez et que même
sur la même sur l'ukraine il ne pourra
pas envahir la totalité du cren comme
c'était son plan initial y pensait qu'en
trois jours sous les acclamations des
ukrainiens salle est un voyage triomphal
et évidemment il n'en est rien
on l'a très mal renseigné je pense nous
pensons du reste qu'il ya des purges
très intense au sein de l'armée russe
parce qu'on l'a et il puni avec la même
sévérité
ceux là même qui l'ont induit en erreur
et qu'il est aujourd'hui je pense qu'il
est seul je pense qu'il est même seule
physiquement en fallait les
renseignements que l'on a pour autant
qu'on puisse l'approcher c'est personne
ne le voit personne parle à personne et
il ne parlait à personne depuis
longtemps
et ça c'est peut-être du reste une des
erreurs que l'occident a pu faire dans
les années qui ont précédé de ne pas
venir le voir suffisamment mais là
maintenant on est dans une situation qui
est tout autre sur la question des
vecteurs ça c'est une information
importante est est ce que vous en savez
plus
pour l'instant vous savez on a des
éléments d'information
on sait que notamment ce chef des
services de renseignement qui avait été
humilié publiquement toutes les
télévisions du monde entier l'an l'ont
vu on suit là il a disparu des radars on
sait qu'il y en a quelques autres
on a aucune on n'a aucune information il
est comme dans une bulle et pour y
pénétrer c'est absolument impossible
donc on a des confidences qui peuvent
être faits sur les réseaux ici ou là
mais pour l'instant rien de sûr rien de
certain et celles qui se sont réunis
hier en visioconférence accusé l'émir
poutine de couvrir la russie et son
peuple de
lui le nationaliste peut-il réagir face
à de telles déclarations
je pense qu'il développe depuis
longtemps la théorie du complot on le
voit vous avez vu ce petit film qui
circule sur les réseaux ou des enfants
des écoles ont les équipes de petits
chars en carton pour commémorer
aujourd'hui le 9 mai donc c'est un
conditionnement psychologique qui
commence dès l'école dès l'enfance et
donc la version que l'on présente est
systématiquement celle d'un complot de
l'occident qui veut mettre à genoux la
russie est donc à partir du moment où
vous inverser le sens des choses et vous
alors que ce sont des comportements qui
sont absolument terribles dire que il ya
44 millions de nazis en ukraine ac c'est
impossible de croire à des idées
pareilles le g7 qui s'est engagé hier
arrêté l'achat de pétrole russe est ce
qu'il aurait fallu le faire avant est ce
qu'on a trop tardé à cons ce genre de
décision je pense que sur les projets
de monsieur poutine
de reconstituer cet empire les signes d'
alertes se sont multipliées à il ya eu
la crimée on a vu comment les choses se
sont passées en syrie on a vu ce qu'il
s'est passé en transnistrie en ossétie
on a cessé d'avoir des témoignages qui
était alarmant et nous avons tous
collectivement
considérer que bon c'était pas bien on a
posé des sanctions qui du reste ont
assez peu d'effet globalement où elles
vont en avoir dans le temps mais enfin
jusqu'à présent pour l'instant la russie
commence à connaître effectivement un
certain nombre de difficultés de pénurie
sur des sujets est pauvre et enclavé
tiennent les sanctions à l'heure
actuelle bas parce que parce que d'abord
la russie n'est pas sans alliés il faut
pas oublier ça il faut pas imaginer que
le monde entier s'est dressé contre la
russie vous avez l'équivalent de près de
3 milliards d'habitants au monde dont
les gouvernements respectifs n'ont pas
pris position contre la russie la chine
a bien évidemment un la chine qui par
intérêt sûrement et par tactique
commerce avec la russie l'inde qui est
toujours dans une situation assez ambigu
car la russie a toujours été un allié de
choix et c'est le premier fournisseur
d'armes de l'inde vous avez beaucoup de
pays africains beaucoup de pays
d'amérique latine qui prennent une
position assez réservés donc quelque
part d'autres réseaux se met en
circulation et on sait bien par exemple
en france que les sanctions qui ont été
prises qu'on lourdement coûté à nos
agriculteurs
eh bien elles ont permis rang russie de
lancer de relancer ou de lancer des
filières de production qui n'existait
pas jusqu'à présent on a parlé des armes
la question fait débat faut-il aller
plus loin au contraire arrêté ses
livraisons pour ne pas apparaître comme
deco belligérants va faire le point avec
alex pour ça
bonjour yann bonjour qu'ils sont encore
bon bonjour
et bienvenue à peu près une quarantaine
de pays qui livrent des armes à
l'ukraine ce sont essentiellement des
membres de l'otan de l'alliance
atlantique alors il ya déjà les membres
de l'union européenne puisque l'union
européenne a pour la première fois
décidé d'armer un pays dans un conflit
ensuite eh bien on peut citer les états
unis bien sûr qui mène cette alliance
pour aider militairement l'ukraine et
puis d'autres pays comme le canada
l'australie le japon et la turquie
ensuite on va regarder quels budgets
sont débloqués pour livrer à ces armes à
l'ukraine et bien en tête de cet
engagement financier il y a les états
unis avec joe biden le président
américain qui a annoncé au total une
enveloppe de 19 milliards d'euros pour
aider militairement l'ukraine 2
milliards d'euros pour les britanniques
1 milliard d'euros pour l'allemagne les
pays baltes voisins de la russie
inquiète de cette guerre participent
également beaucoup et bien à l'armement
des ukrainiens alors du côté de la
france on a mis un point d'interrogation
car paris reste très discret sur les
armes qui sont livrés aux ukrainiens on
sait qu'au moins 100 millions d'euros
d'armement ont pour l'instant été livrée
mais ce montant doit être large
supérieur quand on connaît la puissance
militaire française et puis d'autres
nations débloque des budgets conséquents
comme le danemark et le canada et quel
type d'armes alex
alors au début de la guerre on était
dans un armement léger désarmé
ukrainienne avec des munitions des
solutions de transport qui étaient
fournis et maintenant on passe dans un
armement lourd de l'ukraine si on prend
par exemple les états unis et bien ils
fournissent désormais des lanceurs d'eau
bue au buzzer qui ont une portée de 40
km il livre également des drones tueurs
phoenix ghost c'est à dire des drones
kamikazes des hélicoptères et puis des
missiles javelin on peut dire que le
royaume uni livre des chars à l'ukraine
alors de manière indirecte puisque les
britanniques fournissent des chars aux
polonais qui en échange livre des chars
de fabrication soviétique aux ukrainiens
les ukrainiens sa venue les piloter et
puis le royaume-uni qui apporte aussi au
régime de kiev des véhicules blindés
mais stif et des missiles antichars côté
allemand beaucoup de missiles beaucoup
d'armes antichars sont livré à l'ukraine
l'allemagne a par exemple donné tout son
stock de missiles sol air strella qui
datent de la période soviétique
et puis je le disais un la france est
assez secrète sur les armes qui sont
livrés aux ukrainiens mais emmanuel
macron a fait une déclaration récente
dans la presse dans une interview à
ouest-france il le dit hein nous livrons
quand même d équipement conséquent des
missiles milan au canon caesar les
canons caesar ce sont des obusiers
dernière génération des armes lourdes en
passant par plusieurs types d'armements
emmanuel macron le dire je pense qu'il
faut continuer sur ce chemin avec
toujours une ligne rouge qui est de ne
pas entrer dans la cohue belligérance et
puis il ne faut pas oublier les drones
turc bayraktar tv2 très appréciée de
l'armée ukrainienne dans ce conflit car
ils posent beaucoup de problèmes aux
forces russes christian cambon on voit
les alliés occidentaux fournissent
maintenant un armement lourd à l'ukraine
est ce que c'est une montée en puissance
nécessaire ou une escalade qui quand
même peut être inquiétante
c'est une montée en puissance qui est
nécessaire à partir du moment où
les russes attaque l'ukraine de manière
effroyable il faut véritablement ne pas
se limiter à des déclarations de
solidarité manifesté notre notre
solidarité notre engagement l'ukraine a
fait savoir par différents canaux tous
les besoins qui étaient les siens et il
me semble assez normal que l'occident
manifeste sa solidarité son aide c'est à
dire qu'une demande des
particuliers besoin qu'ils expriment
leurs besoins du reste il le fait
publiquement à chaque intervention
lorsqu'il s'est adressé à différents
parlements notamment etc et puis par par
d'autres canaux que nous connaissons est
bien évidemment
je pense que l'ukraine elle mène ne
s'attendait peut-être pas à la violence
d'un tel conflit donc et ils avaient ils
ont fait des efforts considérables moi
je suis stupéfait de voir et admiratif
de voir le courage de ces gens ont
regardé la résistance à marioupol de
gens qui savent que peut-être demain ils
seront ils seront ils sont morts et
malgré tout ils ne lâchent pas et
véritablement vous savez on le voit
aussi c'est au niveau des réfugiés que
nous accueillons la grande dignité de
ces gens sains et cet amour de la patrie
aussi disons le et donc je pense que
nous nous devons faire notre devoir
c'est insupportable au 21ème siècle
alors que nous pensions nous avons fêté
hier tous le 8 mai 1945
on pensait tous on aurait raconté cette
histoire il ya quelques mois personne
n'y aurait cru et on a un conflit parmi
les pires avec les méthodes ont mouillé
quand on parle maintenant de quasi camps
de concentration de rétention de
centaines de milliers d'ukrainiens que
l'on déplace c'est pas possible on ne
peut pas vivre comme ça dans un monde
pareil ou alors sens à ces états
puissances vont chacun envahir les
voisins et puis
ce sera sans fin et un jour ce sera
effectivement une guerre mondiale ça
veut dire que les occidentaux doivent
assumer le devenir des kobe les gérants
quand on livre quand on livre des
armements lourds des belligérants n'ont
livre désarmons n'est pas il ya aucun
soldat français ni occidentaux
occidental qui se trouve actuellement
sur le territoire ukrainien nous en
avons la certitude vous souhaitez à la
frontière oui les hommes on est
les livraisons d'armes se font
effectivement dans le cas des échanges
classiques existent entre un certain
nombre de pays nos nos armes aboutissent
à des hubs qui se situe dans les pays
voisins et c'est là où les forces du
craignait ne vient d'en prendre
livraison et puis bien sûr nous restons
aussi attentifs moi j'ai eu l'occasion
d'aller voir nos forces françaises à
constanza en roumanie parce que là si un
pays de l'otan il faut quand même
prendre en compte ce genre de choses il
peut y avoir une agression contre un
pays le temps là c'est tout à fait autre
chose il ya le fameux article 5 qui nous
protège les uns et les autres à alex le
disais c'est assez flou en france on
pense avoir
[Musique]
plus de transparence non alors d'abord
nous mêmes en commission à huis clos
nous ne nous livrons aux investigations
nécessaires car le compte le parlement
doit exercer son contrôle mais je pense
que pour des raisons de sécurité
notamment vis-à-vis de ceux là même qui
convoie ses armes il est absolument
nécessaire d'être assez discret c'est
pas la peine de renseigner l'adversaire
sur ce que vous êtes en train de faire
mais ça doit rester au sein de la
commission des affaires étrangères des
deux commissions afin
qu'il faut un débat plus large en parle
maintenant non non pour l'instant je
pense que il ya d'abord un consensus
vous voyez mais il faudra que dans le
futur
lorsque les choses se seront calmées le
parlement aille à un tout petit peu plus
loin sur ces sujets y compris du ray sur
le réarmement qui doit continuer en
france et là puisqu'on est en pleine
période d'élection il va falloir que les
candidats s'expriment ceux qui vont être
à l'assemblée nationale et qui doivent
nous dire très clairement si ils vont
accompagner le mouvement de renforcement
de nos forces armées moi je sais où sont
les points faibles où sont les
difficultés que nous connaissons et donc
nous accompagnerons tout gouvernement
qui effectivement assurera ce réarmement
dont la france a absolument besoin
de l'armée française est-ce que là il ya
un virage
en ukraine la sphère des munitions et
u10 fr nous l'avons dit à travers
différents rapports simplement
maintenant on en prend conscience
d'autant qu'en plus on puisse sur nos
munitions parce que les munitions qu'on
lise c'est pas des munitions qu'on
achète dans dix ans dans des industries
sont des munitions que nous avons dans
nos arsenaux donc il va falloir re et
réapprovisionner tout cela est
nous avons auditionné le dial délégué
général à l'armement la semaine dernière
et il ya effectivement des mesures qui
sont actuellement que prises pour
reconstituer des stocks dont vous pouvez
parler ou pas donc je ne peux pas parler
merci alex évidemment dans le club des
territoires on va continuer à parler de
ces sujets notamment de la question de
l'otan va aller à rennes a retrouvé le
mari romain grosjean ex mari merci
beaucoup pour jour être avec nos
journalistes à ouest-france et
yves-marie justement à la une de ouest
france aujourd'hui la finlande se
rapproche de l'otan effectivement depuis
l'invasion de l'ukraine les finlandais
et leur gouvernement semble décidé à
rejoindre le temps le fragile équilibre
qui existait depuis la seconde guerre
mondiale avec l'encombrant voisin russe
paraît brisé deux journalistes de notre
rédaction se sont rendus dans ce pays
aux 5 millions d'habitants pendant une
semaine afin d'en prendre le pouls pour
le député en qu'il y de mal qu'ils ont
rencontré l'invasion l'ukraine a prouvé
à quel point la russie pouvait être
agressive et imprévisibles îles sondages
montrent d'ailleurs combien le
changement est profond en finlande il y
a quelques mois seuls 20% des habitants
étaient favorables à l'adhésion à l'otan
aujourd'hui c'est plus de 65% la russie
a fait une erreur historique poursuit le
député anti l'île de man cette invasion
a uni le peuple ukrainien à l'union
européenne et à changer la manière de
penser des finlandais au sujet de l'otan
alors le débat parlementaire ouvert le
27 avril devrait probablement rendre son
verdict prochainement la finlande
représentera traverse vraisemblablement
sa candidature à l'otan fin juin à
madrid une question inquiète les députés
combien de temps prendra cette procédure
d'adhésion si nous faisons ce choix il
faudrait que cela se fasse le plus
rapidement possible afin de réduire les
risques concluante elite man alors
christian cambon les fans indiens ont
ils raison de vouloir intégrer l'otan et
surtout d'être inquiets face à la russie
ils ont raison d'intégrer l'otan puisque
finalement le temps que dont le
président de la république avait pu
pointer les faiblesses i mais on a
l'impression que c'était à l'autre
siècle est bien là
non comme une véritable garantie encore
une fois je cite l'exemple de la
romaniquette en proximité immédiate avec
l'ukraine et qui se sent évidemment
beaucoup plus sécurisé et que nous
sécurisons y compris avec la présence de
forces françaises américaines
britanniques et c est donc là le temps
est effectivement une véritable garantie
que les finlandais les suédois craignent
des mesures de rétorsion oui je
comprends tout à fait parce que d'abord
ces menaces ont été proférées et
évidemment c'est un des effets un vrai
c'est d'un des effets collatéraux de
cette attitude de de la russie c'est
finalement d'avoir rendu beaucoup plus
cohérent à la fois l'europe l'union
européenne et aussi les forces de l'otan
moi même je je je je siège à l'assemblée
parlementaire de l'otan et effectivement
on voit que les choses sont en train de
bouger pour renforcer nos moyens parce
que c'est le temps apparaît aujourd'hui
comme une garantie et une assurance ce
qui nécessitera néanmoins que chaque
pays européens continuent à faire des
efforts en matière d'armement car on ne
peut pas systématiquement quand tu
arrives des drames de cette sorte dire
mon voisin va me protéger il faut que
chacun fasse des efforts la france a
commencé à le faire il faut qu'elle
continue d'autres pays le font
l'allemagne 100 milliards sur la table
100 milliards pour sa défense n'est pas
rien pour un pays qui avait vis-à-vis de
ces armes est une attitude assez
assez attentiste et donc le temps
effectivement redevient une garantie moi
je comprends très bien que la finlande
qui a quand même des centaines de
kilomètres de frontière avec la russie
regarde les choses avec beaucoup de
circonspection et c'est une des
conséquences que monsieur poutine va
devoir supporter ces damnés d'avoir
rassemblé l'occident comme il ne l'était
pas précédemment sur la deuxième partie
de la question de démarrer parce que la
russie dit déjà qu'une adhésion de la
finlande mènerait de lourdes
conséquences politiques
militaire est ce que ça risque d'être
oui j'imagine la colère c'est une chose
à l'homme à nancy tente d action
militaire contre la finlande la en
changent effectivement de rayon si j'ose
dire et je crois et le président de la
république de finlande que qu'avec le
président larcher nous avons reçu il ya
peu de temps nous a bien dit
qu'effectivement entre le temps de la
demande et le temps de la mise en oeuvre
il faudrait qu'ils aient assez peu de il
faudrait que le délai soit assez court
pour qu'il n'y ait pas des menaces et
des pressions mais on sait que la la la
russie sur toutes les zones qui avoisine
son propre territoire n'est pas avare de
menaces mais il ya un moment où il faut
choisir l'avenir que l'on souhaite et je
pense qu'effectivement la finlande est
tout à fait dans son droit d'abord un
choix démocratique 6 à 65 % des gens
dans un pays qui était très hostile très
hostile si à 65 % des gens qui veulent
adhérer le temps dans des régimes
démocratiques ce sont des éléments qui
comptent j'attire du reste la tension
puisque nous sommes en période
électorale sur ceux qui prétendent qu'il
convient de sortir de l'otan car il faut
mesurer les paroles et les engagements
que l'on prend on recevra une fois tu as
oui ce serait un désastre un désastre
juste à un dernier mot là dessus parce
que l'entrée de la finlande dans l'otan
ça serait plus 2000
nouveaux kilomètres de frontière à
sécuriser pour l'otan c'est une
responsabilité qui est complètement
assumable ça va être difficile on
l'assumera le temps l'assumera le seul
le compte vous savez je pense que
franchement cette affaire de la russie
est en train de modifier tous nos
logiciels on va devoir revoir nous mêmes
nos armements notre défense aérienne
nous munitions tout notre mise en
condition opérationnelle tout ça va
devoir être revu ça prendra du temps ça
coûtera beaucoup d'argent mais il faut
savoir si effectivement nos populations
qui désirent vivre en sécurité c'est la
première chose que des dirigeants
doivent à leur pays c'est vivant
sécurité il faut en payer le prix alors
si effectivement comme c'était le cas
jadis on disait dans les dépenses
d'armement ça suffit nous sommes dans un
pacifisme tout à fait et irénique et
tout va bien se passer les faits
montrent le contraire et moi je ne
souhaite pas que mon pays connaissent
aucun pays voisins amis comme la
finlande ou autres connaisse le sort de
ce que nous voyons en ukraine et donc
c'est pour ça qu'il faudra se donner les
moyens se doter des moyens nécessaires
et des les pays qui font cet effort à
l'accomplir il m'arrive d'aller nous
parlait de la moldavie est la moins
d'avis retient son souffle
effectivement en ce lundi 9 mai jour de
la démonstration de force de la russie
un autre pays tremble la moldavie après
plusieurs attaques en transnistrie ces
dernières heures une enclave moldave pro
russe ce petit pays de 2,5 millions
d'habitants non membre de l'otan craint
de voir le conflit déborder chez lui la
transnistrie quand en effet déjà douze
mille militaires russes sur son sol et
des milieux de tonnes d'armes selon igor
mon nutella ou politologue de l'institut
moldavie ils disent que nous
interviewons ce matin des débordements
sont effectivement à craindre dans toute
la moldavie ce lundi le kremlin pour en
profiter pour affirmer que les droits
des russophones ils sont baffier wafou
et ce qui pourrait générer une escalade
voir une intervention militaire de son
côté le président russe ukrainien
volodimir et l'ins qui craint que les
soldats pro riche de transnistrie ne
prenne l'ukraine à revers du côté
d'odessa voir au sud de la moldavie
alors christian cambon maya sand ou là
résidente moldave est une pro européenne
une intervention russe en moldavie est
ce la ligne rouge à ne surtout pas de
franchir pour l'union européenne à il
est sûr que une nouvelle agression
vis-à-vis de la moldavie qui est un
petit pays excessivement peau et qui n'a
quasiment pas d'armé en plus poserait un
véritable problème là l'occident serait
à nouveau confronté à une situation
assez identique à l'ukraine puisque je
rappelle que la moldavie ne fait pas
partie de l'otan néanmoins là aussi
c'est un pays que nous aidons de manière
discrète mais efficace
nous avons effectivement un certain
nombre de contacts dans ce sens parce
que là ça montrerait une nouvelle fois
que poutine franchi une étape
supplémentaire et ça menacerait il ya
d'autres pays qui ont aussi
regardé ce qui s'est passé en géorgie on
se souvient de ce que sarkozy était venu
arrêter au tout début de son mandat donc
il faut mettre un coup d'arrêt à
l'expansionnisme
de la russie or nous avons l'impression
que la russie ne croit qu'à la force
puisque toutes les négociations toutes
les conversations qu'ont pu avoir et qui
ont acquis aller dans le bon sens et qui
partait d'une bonne intention mais ne
débouche sur pas grand chose puisque
aujourd'hui on est à plus de deux mois
d'une guerre effroyable et rien ne se
passe effectivement les menaces sur la
moldavie sont assez inquiétantes pour
nous mais il
le statut de la moldavie ne permet pas
pour l'instant d'agir comme vous pour l
agir au sein de l'otan merci le mari aux
banques d'avoir et du cim aujourd'hui à
la une de ouest france menace russe la
finlande se rapproche de l'otan c'est à
la une de votre journal merci beaucoup
ils se marient robin
[Musique]